[Music]  [Music]  does it bother you that I'm not  completely human you were the most human  person I have ever met  [Music]  didn't I tell you to be home before dark  I just lost track of time  Alida you have to be responsible where's  someone very special hey kid  not just a teenage girl hey what's your  problem you can't remember what do you  mean doc found you in the scrap yard so  you must be from not there and I'm just  an insignificant girl that's what they  want you to think  I'm not your daughter I don't know what  I am I do  yeah the most advanced weapon ever  but that's just a shell it's not that or  good that part's up to you  I do not stand by  [Music]  the presence of evil  she's threatening the natural order of  things  tonight is not a game  it is a hot  I need you to destroy the girl called  Aleta  you made the biggest mistake of your  life  and what's that  under estimating Who I am  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]